[Musique]
je suis père médecin genre de
papineauville
j'élève des chevaux les beaux chevaux
que j'adore
on a acheté ici pour la bonne bouche et
puis avec un qui lui met un cheval non
pas parce qu'il y avait du beau gosse
moi j'ai commencé je vais rien
connaissances et mon pain fall sabin
grosse de babel peur j'ai fait affaire
avec une madame qui avait des chevaux de
course
elle avait neuf étalons puis à bridas
250 à 300 logements par année
on avait des ententes question les
enfants chez nous j'ai eu l'occasion
d'avoir des gens de montréal qui ont
l'humeur des juments poulinières en
pension puis le jeu mais d'abord le baby
après cela les affaires non-vie rejoint
donc au kentucky ou alentours de retour
dans le monde du 6 8 db par année les
journées mais thébaux est entamée bobin
on est là pour le bébé mais on lui donne
le premier col et seront même à mike
siège faut remettre des hommes sur un
aubry d'autres bébés bay à north bay qui
et quand je suis parti sans vouloir
entrer comme enfin avec les batteries
pdg des chevaux de course joke et de
kentucky et de mes amis de ouais j'en ai
un même qui est allé jusqu'à morgue un
colosse est exceptionnel avec mon corps
heureuse chose à des chevaux de
compétition
puis tous ces bébés ont qualifié surtout
dans les bas vite cédé qu'à bord il
court alentours des barris
moi je gardais défaut pour les autres
c'est pour moi qui faisais là bien un
dicton dit si tu veux faire une petite
fortune ont commencé par une grosse les
hommes avec l'argent et ces femmes qui
n'étaient pas des fonds s'ils avaient
encore mais on partait pour ian r si on
descendait au kentucky steve femmes qui
descendent est présent parce que aux
états ou groupes pour qu'il y ait 10 ou
[Applaudissements]
16 mètres à faire je voyais un jour et
nuit
celui là autant votre il faudra qu'il en
dise où vous devenez amener ça nous fait
chaud au moins 5
j'ai commencé 1,55 à peu près on voit
quelle chaîne puis on ne bien faire ton
au chili on faisait des grandes
randonnées sur la rivière 1 quand un
joli dans les traits de ce qui double
des vrais de nuit avec une pochette et
radio pyromane que ce bébé naulleau je
sais que c'est mon dernier
il va être difficile de sortir de ma
main de ma vue elle changé comme emi
nous ta bulle et trulli devienne membre
à ses deux pilotes
il se remet tout ce que tu lui donneras
your love you i love you vous traitez
sur gentiment comme entre autres notre
homme non
cette maman on t'aime moi j'ai eu la
plus belle vie l'éthologie je parlais au
ciel a cependant dit que le ciel n'est
pas d'animaux